these are tough times for EU solidarity
and cohesion Britain threatening to
leave the club if its people vote
against membership the schengen
agreement on a borderless Europe also
under threat from the tide of refugees
just two of the hot topics under
discussion in next week's plenary
session in Strasbourg I think the
beginning you could deal has Britain's
Prime Minister David Cameron secured a
deal with his European compatriots on
the package of reforms he's been pushing
for the outcome of tough negotiations on
issues like the single market migrant
welfare rights and the depth of
integration should be announced in
February on it potentially hangs the
future of the UK in the EU in Parliament
there'll be a debate on Wednesday on
February's meeting of EU heads of state
and government at which the negotiations
with the UK will be the headline topic
along with migration
talking of migration the Schengen area
almost four and a half million square
kilometers of border Free Europe is also
under threat with some countries
reintroducing border controls to manage
the flow of refugees some people say if
Shannon is under threat the European
Union itself is also under threat so
where is Shannon headed mep s will try
to answer that in a debate on Tuesday
also on Tuesday the three billion euro
package devoted to helping Turkey deal
with gigantic flows of Syrian refugees
and stop them travelling on to Europe
will come under scrutiny during a debate
I work therefore I am but what if I
don't declare the work I do does it
follow from a purely philosophical point
of view that I work therefore I am NOT
it's a conundrum too far for the EU
which is seeking to create a platform to
help member states fight undeclared work
away they say to boost the formal job
market and combat bogus self-employment
and tax evasion Parliament will debate
the issue on Tuesday and now for some
other news in brief on Tuesday the
president of Estonia Thomas Henry kill
this will be making a keynote address
with the president of Nigeria Muhammadu
Buhari elected last year making the
platform the following day on Wednesday
em eps will debate ending sexual
harassment of women in public places
this follows the new year sexual
assaults in germany also on Tuesday emmy
peace will vote on a plan to trade pact
22 countries designed to build trade and
banking telecoms and health this is the
trade in services agreement or tea set
finally MEP s will have the chance to
demonstrate their determination to
reduce the harmful effects of diesel
emissions in Europe following the VW
emissions fixing scandal last year
they'll vote on a proposal to veto
European Commission plans to raise the
limits for nitrogen oxides by more than
one hundred percent arguing the rise
would undermine the enforcement of
existing EU standards vote will take
place on Wednesday that's it from a
packed and varied agenda enjoy the week